[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le journal de
tv 78 nous sommes le mardi 20 avril
voici les titres de cette édition
emmanuel macron avait fixé le cap
rouvrir les lieux fermés à partir de la
mi-mai une réouverture qui semble
possible sur pour les terrasses des bars
et restaurants mais qui pourrait être et
territorialisée se faire étape par étape
en attendant les établissements vivent
dans l'espoir d'un feu vert présidentiel
reportage et un invité jean noël barrot
député de la 2e circonscription des
yvelines
dans ce contexte n'est pas une surprise
le secteur du tourisme a
particulièrement souffert en 2020 dans
les yvelines
c'est l'enseignement des derniers
chiffres publiés à ce sujet par le
conseil départemental moitié moins de
séjours hôteliers des sites touristiques
eu presque déserté le point à suivre et
si vous deveniez candidat à l'élection
présidentielle ce jeu de société vous
propose en tout cas de vous lancer dans
une campagne électorale
la course à la présidence a été imaginé
par un aiguillon courtois l'objectif
remporté le scrutin par tous les moyens
on parle également dans cette édition
d'un autre scrutin à venir la municipale
partielle qui est au programme en mai à
chevreuse pour débuter comme chaque
mardi les chiffres de la vaccination
dans les yvelines au 19 avril 221 1039
personnes ont reçu une première
injection 24000 de plus par rapport au
lundi 12 avril est la campagne se
poursuit donc cette semaine près de
32000 rendez vous sont pris dans les 16
centres de vaccination du département et
dont un peu moins de 15 milles pour une
seconde injection est la vaccination est
ouverte désormais aux plus de 55 ans
avec des créneaux réservés pour les
professions prioritaires et notamment
les enseignants les professionnels de la
petite enfance les policiers les
gendarmes ou encore les surveillants
pénitentiaires
[Musique]
mais mi mai début juin ou encore juillet
les dates de réouverture pour les bars
et restaurants se précise petit à petit
elle le président de la république en
réunion avec quelques maires le 15 avril
dernier a laissé entendre que le
troisième déconfinement se ferait par
étapes
une situation difficile pour certaines
professions rencontre avec un
restaurateur et le gérant d'un bar à
montigny le bretonneux c'est avec
mélanie poké des jeux qui n'attendent
qu'à retrouver leur passionnés au manga
bas les équipes patiente mais avec leur
terrasse et une extension proposé par la
mairie
l'humeur est plutôt au beau fixe on
n'est pas dépité
maintenant c'est vrai que on croit en
nos deux bars et en obtient un hôtel on
y sont là ils sont présents on les voit
qu'on en ait plus avancée qui va être là
l'ouverture
maintenant c'est vrai que pour nous au
niveau de la gestion qu'on a un petit
peu dépité mais disons qu'on a perdu
alors la gestion a pris du retard voire
même deux ans puisqu'il va falloir en
nombre pour pouvoir rattraper le retard
de cette année les propriétaires ont mis
les différents confinement à profit pour
améliorer leurs cartes avant mars 2020
le manga bas réalisé un chiffre
d'affaires mensuel de 50000 euros
allez voir s'activer en cuisine on
pourrait croire que tout a déjà repris
mais damien bouteloup et son équipe sont
aux fourneaux pour les plats à emporter
300 couverts sur quatre jours
le ch a fini mon teint prend son mal en
patience je pense que l'on a ainsi subi
voilà maintenant on continue notre job
satisfaire comme les clients qui
continuent à venir chez nous et puis bah
quand ça vous verra je pense que je
serai le premier à 2 5% donc voilà on
attend on est dans la tente
on a essayé de rénover un peu les
cuisines pendant la profité aussi pour
faire d'autres de trois travaux
maintenant on attend de voir ce qu'ils
vont nous dire lasser rapidement pour le
tablier aussi la terrasse sera la
première bouffée d'air frais le
président de la république a fixé à mi
mai la date de réouverture et pour
parler de ce sujet invités de ce journal
jean noël barrot député de la 2e
circonscription des yvelines qui n'est
pas encore parvenu à nous rejoindre il
pourra le faire d'ici la fin de cette
édition
en attendant la réouverture des
restaurateurs de mantes-la-jolie propose
tous les samedis de la vente à emporter
à la place sant maclou et ce depuis le
27 mars dernier la municipalité leur a
prêté des chalets de noël inutilisés
pendant cette période le reportage
d'astrid bergère justin brasier et joe
sakala le printemps est là et pourtant
la saint maclou à mantes la jolie
les chalets de noël sont sortis tous les
samedis depuis le 27 mars des
restaurateurs profitent de ces
installations
prêté par la commune pour faire de la
vente à emporter on encourager ce projet
parce qu'on a eu des demandes des
restaurateurs qui nous prônons proposé
l'idée et on a trouvé que c'était une
excellente idée que de permettre aux
restaurateurs qui sont quand même 12
mois durement touché par la crise de
pouvoir reprendre contact avec leurs
clients en extérieur en respectant
évidemment les gestes de sanitaires des
restaurateurs différents sont présents
chaque semaine avec une carte légèrement
différente de ce qu'ils proposent
habituellement mais la qualité elle
restait de mise et les professionnels
s'en réjouisse c'est déjà un pas en
avant qui recrée de l'enthousiasmé et de
la motivation et de l'espoir surtout de
réouvrir assez rapidement aujourd'hui en
plus on a un beau temps donc on espère
pouvant roman réouvrir bientôt les
terrasses puis à terme ré ouvrir
normalement et les clients répondent
présents et en demandent encore plus le
fait de voir le visuel
évidemment ça donne envie et puis ça m'a
l'air bien bon parce que dans les
responsables et autres endroits c'est
difficile de trouver des caps n'était
comme tech jeux venus soutenir les
restaurateurs loca pas demande
c'est très bien mais je trouve qu'il
manque de chalais ce serait bien qu'ils
aient un peu plus de restaurateurs si
toutes on connaît pas tout le monde donc
qu'on puisse faire connaissance avec nos
commerçants le village de restaurateurs
sera ouvert tous les samedis de 11h à
14h pour le salé et de 11h à 16h pour le
sucré et ce jusqu'à la réouverture des
établissements et dans ce contexte le
bilan est sans surprise la fréquentation
touristique dans les yvelines a été
profondément touché par la crise
sanitaire près de 50% de baisse pour les
séjours hôteliers plus de 60 % de
visites en moins dans les sites
touristiques ont fait le point avec
mélanie poké elle est considérée comme
catastrophique dans les yvelines dans le
secteur de l'hôtellerie la perte de
chiffre d'affaires pour l'année 2020 et
2 54% en moyenne les locations de
vacances sont-elles relativement épargné
avec une baisse de 17% ce qui est très
important de se dire c'est que on s'y
retrouver avec une majorité de clients
français ce qui est plutôt pas mal mais
la clientèle internationale
les seuls qui ont perduré un petit peu
sont les belles âmes qui ont continué de
venir une perte de visiteurs qui se
ressent aussi dans les sites
touristiques et culturels parmi les dix
lieux les plus visités en 2020 le
château de versailles france miniature
et la bergerie nationale sont les plus
touchés on a fait des actions qui
étaient très liées justement à la
pandémie et avec par exemple les
quartiers d'été puisque les quartiers
d'été bien sûr s'était tourné vers la
jeunesse et vers les enfants des
quartiers un petit peu en difficulté
mais ça a permis aussi à une trentaine
de professionnels du tourisme et bien
d'accueillir à des jeunes aidés par le
département alors que les centres de
loisirs étaient fermés les
professionnels sont partagés pour un
retour espéré à la normale entre 4 mois
et un an
le département va de son côté continuer
à proposer le pass malin un nouveau site
internet sera aussi proposée à
la fin de l'année 2021 pour répondre aux
nouvelles attentes des touristes et sai
et jean-noël barrot nous a rejoint par
visioconférence bonsoir bon ça va être
le député de la 2e circonscription des
yvelines vice président de la commission
des finances à l'assemblée nationale et
j'ajoute que vous êtes également le
secrétaire général du modem on parle
avec vous de cette attente autour de la
réouverture des restaurants et bars et
ont proposé tout à l'heure à nos
téléspectateurs un sujet avec des
restaurateurs des gérants de bars qui
ont un espoir pour cette réouverture on
a entendu de l'optimisme dans ce sujet
mais aussi malgré tout un peu de crainte
et de fatigue et une certaine forme
d'impatience de pouvoir ouvrir surtout
que c'est chez certains des voisins
européens de la france
les terrasses ont pu rouvrir est ce que
vous entendez qui est une certaine forme
une certaine forme pardon d'impatience
justement ah oui je comprends la
lassitude et l inquiétude et je partage
l'espoir qu'on puisse rouvrir le plus
tôt possible pour que l'activité de ces
cafés de ses restaurants puisse
reprendre évidemment mais aussi pour que
toute la vie sociale dont ses cafés ses
restaurants sont sans le lieu central
puisse elle aussi reprendre puisque nous
ne saurions vivre ou continuer à vivre
aussi éloignés les uns des autres que
nous l'avons fait depuis ces derniers
mois
d'autant qu'aujourd'hui on n'a toujours
pas de date officielle de réouverture
même s'il porte parole du gouvernement
gabriela talent a précisé aux échos que
certaines terrasses pourrait rouvrir à
la mi mai mais il ya tout de même un
flou encore sur la date officielle
quelle région aussi seront concernés un
petit flou tout de même autour de cette
question
vous avez vu les les
la manière dont le virus et l'épidémie
s'est comporté de manière totalement
imprévisible depuis un an
[Musique]
il ya un an jour pour jour nous étions
confinés
avec l'espoir que le à la mi-mai nous
puissions retrouver une vie normale et à
la mi-mai nous envisagions toutes et
tous que l'été allez voir le retour à la
normale la fin définitive du virus et
nous voici un an plus tard confiné à
nouveau donc il faut dans cette matière
sanitaire faire preuve de la plus grande
prudence et à la fois évidemment
envisager un calendrier de réouverture
c'est un peu ce que le président de la
république a fait là un point qu'il
s'est exprimé mais tout en étant
extrêmement prudents les manière à ne
pas créer de faux espoirs
justement de ce qui a filtré des
échanges qu'ils aient pu avoir emmanuel
macron avec les maires et aussi les
ministres il ya un maître mot qui est
ressorti c'est la progressivité
réouverture de certaines terrasses et
des musées à la mi mai à partir de la
mi-mai puis de nouvelles étapes toutes
les trois semaines avec pourquoi pas les
lieux culturels les salles des bars et
restaurants par exemple ça c'est un
impératif d'y aller étape par étape de
jauger à chaque fois avant d'ouvrir
davantage
oui il faut être attentif on est menacé
par de nouveaux variants y compris ceux
qui nous viennent du brésil qui sont
extrêmement contagieux de plus en plus
contagieux et donc il faut que nous
prenions le temps de faire les choses
progressivement de manière à ce que la
vaccination qui a beaucoup accéléré
puissent être pleinement déployée est
que nous arrivions dans les premiers
jours de l'été dans une situation où les
choses peuvent réouvrir les gens peuvent
se retrouver les familles peuvent se
revoir et que la vie reprenne son cours
autre stratégie qui a été qui pourrait
être appliquée c'est celle de la
territorialisation en fonction des
situations dans les régions situation
sanitaire rouvrir certains lieux dans
certaines les laisser fermer dans
d'autres ce qui n'a pas été forcément
qu'un lors du premier à des confinement
et la réouverture de ces bars et
restaurants en juin 2020 ça aussi ça ça
a du sens oui de prendre les décisions
région par région comme on le voit
depuis plusieurs mois avec et bien c'est
couvre-feu c'est confinement qui ont été
parfois décrété à des échelles
régionales oui ça avait beaucoup de sens
et je
je me suis félicité que de telles
décisions soient prises il a fallu
confiné l'ensemble du territoire parce
que la situation devenait intenable mais
je crois qu'effectivement si nous
pouvons rester dans un esprit de de
territorialité qui tienne compte des
spécificités locales ce sera la bonne
manière de procéder
concernant les protocoles de réouverture
des négociations sont en cours les
syndicats voudraient une application des
mêmes règles que lors de la dernière
haie ou vertueux on pense forcément à la
distance d'un mètre entre les tables le
nombre maximum d'occupants par table
port du masque obligatoire tant que l'on
n'est pas assis à à table c'est un
protocole qu applicable qu il faut
renforcer selon vous moi je suis pas
malheureusement experts dans ce domaine
là mais je sais qu'on saura tenir compte
de tout ce qu'on a pu apprendre depuis
un an sur la propagation de ce virus
pour essayer de donner le cadre qui
s'imposent pour préserver la santé des
salariés et des clients tout en évitant
de contraindre trop la vie sociale la
vie économique
il ya d'autres en tout cas protocole qui
ont été évoqués l'utilisation de qr
codes à l'entrée des terrasses qui a été
également évoquée pour tracer les cas
contacts on parle aussi de plus en plus
de ce pass sanitaire qui est un nouvel
outil qui doit intégrer l'application
tout senti qu vide qui pourra contenir
les résultats des tests pcr ainsi qu'une
attestation de vaccination il faut les
rendre nécessaire pour accéder aux
terrasses peut être accéder plus tard
aux salles des restaurants c'est un
outil dont on peut se doter aujourd'hui
un bon outil françois bayrou aulas l'a
évoqué parmi les tout premiers
l'idée c'est évidemment qu'on puisse
avoir une bonne information sur la
sérologie des des personnes qui se
déplacent candidats franchir une
frontière ou qui pour accéder à
certaines
manifestation des expérimentations qui
ont été menées dans des salles de
spectacles pour que le moment venu les
choses puissent être généralisée il faut
en revanche pour que le principe
d'égalité ne soit jamais brisée qu' on
puisse offrir à chacun et à chacune la
possibilité d'être vacciné tester dès
lors qu'on déploie une solution comme ne
se passe anita voilà pour cette
réouverture en tout cas cet espoir de
réouverture avec peut-être une première
date à la mi-mai une réouverture qui se
ferait ensuite étape par étape et on en
attend bien sûr des annonces officielles
et définitif du gouvernement merci jean
noël barrot d'avoir été avec nous député
de la 2e circonscription des yvelines
dans l'actualité également la plainte
déposée par la ratp cette action fait
suite à l'incendié d'un bus à
sartrouville bus de la ligne 2 172 les
faits se sont déroulés dimanche soir
vers 23 heures à l'arrêt berry est deux
individus sont montés à bord et ont fait
descendre le conducteur et les passagers
avant de mettre le feu au véhicule il a
été entièrement détruit par les flammes
l'abribus a été également endommagé
aucun blessé n'est à déplorer le
chauffeur prise en charge par son
encadrement suite à cet incident la
ligne circule à nouveau mais le secteur
est contournée l enquête a été confiée à
la sûreté départementale des yvelines
au chapitre politique les 6 et 9 mai
prochains les habitants de cheuvreux
sont appelés aux urnes ni pour les
départementales ni pour les régionales
mais bien pour élire leur maire car
l'élection municipale de 2020 a été
annulée les détails d'eléonore sinoquet
le 15 mars 2020 les élections
municipales se dérouler un peu partout
en france à chevreuse un peu plus de
5000 habitants étaient appelés aux urnes
pour choisir entre deux listes celle de
la maire sortante à néry le pallec ou
bien celle de sébastien de catane et ouf
et le résultat surprenant seulement une
voix d'écart entre les deux candidats
bien que l'abstention soit la grande
gagnante de cette élection c'est à néry
le pallec qui a été réélu chevreuse 2020
est victime de ce scrutin
alors qu'ils auraient été dues a déclaré
vainqueur
une vingtaine de voir candidat
malheureux sébastien cattaneo lance
alors un recours au tribunal
administratif pour faire annuler
l'élection le 7 juillet 2020 le tribunal
juge qu'un des bulletins pour sébastien
cattaneo a été invalidée à tort 1014
voix contre 1014 voix égalité parfaite
l'élection est donc annulée mais le 6
août 2020 à néry le pallec fait appel de
cette décision le 12 mars 2021 le
conseil d'état confirme le premier
jugement
une nouvelle élection doit être organisé
on savait que les tribunaux en matière
d'élection quand les résultats sont
serrés sont assez enclin à annuler donc
on n'a pas été franchement surpris suite
à ces jugements le conseil municipal est
dissous et une délégation spéciale gère
alors les affaires courantes de la ville
de chevreuse l'élection municipale
partielle
elle est prévue les 9 et 16 mai prochain
une campagne électorale express en
pleine crise sanitaire
on va faire là je dirais la campagne qui
s'impose au mans avec quelques papiers
quand même en boîte aux lettres parce
qu'on peut pas se passer il ya quand
même des anciens chevreuse un peu de
visio et puis on continue nous on est
sur le terrain tout le temps on continue
donc quelques nouveautés mais c'est je
dirais que c'est une continuité c'est
hyper frustrant de se dire que l'on n'a
pas les contacts qu'on peut avoir
d'habitude c'est voilà on va alors ça va
être quoi à l'ancienne le boîtage
traditionnelle et puis le côté un petit
peu plus geek un petit peu plus moderne
des réseaux sociaux les réunions à
distance et on touchera pas tout le
monde c'est dommage des listes adapté
des priorités revue pour les candidats à
la mairie de chevreuse crise sanitaire
oblige une seule crainte pour les deux
listes que l'abstention soit de nouveau
la grande gagnante de cette élection et
on reste dans l'univers des campagnes
électorales pour refermer ce journal un
habitant de guyancourt a créé un jeu de
société son nom la course à la
présidence le but est d'incarner un
candidat à une élection et de la
remporté par tous les moyens une
cagnotte en ligne a été lancée il ya
deux semaines pour financer pour aider à
financer le projet astrid bergère et
célia 400 go participer à une campagne
présidentielle et tenter de remporter
une élection c'est le
du nouveau jeu de société la course à la
présidence créé par un habitant de
guyancourt l'idée lui est venue liens
non je pense que le premier confinement
l'a tous vécu différemment nous on a
fait pas mal de jeux de société monde
pour mieux avec les jeux qu'on avait et
au bout d'un moment je suis dit pourquoi
pas essayer de créer un jeu moyenne donc
donc je les fais je me suis lancée on a
fait quelques parties on a bien bébé et
et voilà comment c'est venu à partir de
12 ans entre deux et six personnes
peuvent jouer le but
incarnez un candidat et réussir par tous
les moyens à remporter des électeurs au
fur et à mesure des tours on va devoir
prendre la décision à chaque à chaque
moment de notre campagne finalement de
prendre tel ou tel investissement pour
développer sa stratégie de campagne
donc ça va être soit via des promesses
politiques soit via des actions ou des
descartes coups bas pour aller attaquer
les adversaires le but n'est pas
d'éduquer à la politique mais simplement
de jouer et avec beaucoup de second
degré le jeu est disponible en
précommande sur un site de financement
participatif en attendant sa sortie en
magasin
si tout va bien des je vais les recevoir
à partir de septembre si si si les
délais sont respectés
je pourrais directement envoyées dans
certaines boutiques partenaires qui
accepteront de les vendre donc déjà dans
les boutiques aux alentours et après au
fur et à mesure toutes les boutiques qui
seront intéressés en france
la gagnate warning lancé il y a deux
semaines a déjà atteint 80 % de son
objectif
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant vous avez
rendez vous avec le 7-8 culture
présentée par justine brasier belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]